[Music]
good afternoon everyone and my name is
Ari Muir I'm a product manager in Google
cloud healthcare my team is focusing on
medical imaging solutions so it's my
privilege and pleasure today to host dr.
Kate Amara visiting us from Hiroshima
Japan he and his team are here to tell
you a little bit about an interesting
company called MMS and their work so one
of the actually learned about eminences
work from a friend of mine and one of
the things I found especially
interesting is that they were able to
build a full teleradiology solution
cloud native so they started from the
cloud and they did it without ever
speaking to anyone technical in Google
so they're using AI they using a full
radiology stack they build their own
viewer and they have full time
developers they have full time
radiologists on their team they will
tell you more but without ever speaking
to Google so that's like one of the
examples of how self-service customer so
I would like to start by showing you a
clip a quick clip to give you a
high-level overview and then we're gonna
be discussing different aspects of this
of this work
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so before we move on to the
presentation I would like to suggest you
look for the movie stars among because
there are some people near Tate near you
but dr. Kimura welcome to cloud next
it's pleasure having you here thank you
too it's great to be here so tell us a
little bit about MMS what did you
company do after graduating from
University my first job was radiologist
at a big Hospital in Hiroshima I saw
money in substances in clinical practice
which I wanted to address amnesty is a
terror radiologist company based in
Hiroshima providing radiology service to
hospital in Japan so so what was the
problem you were trying to address one
day a patient was brought to the
hospital she was 37 year old with
advanced pancreatic cancer I checked her
previous results of medical check-up
from 6 month ago I explained an exam in
the old city image and yes can serve us
there and it was missed
so how does how does this happen
how does one miss a cancer thus the
patient had her CT scan at the small
village with limited access to a
radiologist it was miss diagnosis that
could have been prevented this insolent
broke my heart and opened my eyes this
why I started my company a menace to
focus on terror radiology and bring
expertise well it's most needed so in
your mind like how does teleradiology
help here before I explain how to read
teleradiology can help you let me share
with you three dimensions of the
challenges the first dimension is the
ratio of number of radiologists to
number of images created the second
dimension is geographical uniqueness of
Japan as an island nation and finally
the third third dimension is the social
we need our uniqueness of Japanese
health care system interesting so what
do you mean when you say the ratio
here's some data in radiology this
spring in Japan yawn us if you look at
the number of city and the Ammar units
in each country you see that US and
Japan pretty close but if you look at
the number of radiologists you will see
that you will say has ten times the
number of radiologists
compared to Japan one a recent we
chatted with an American colleague he
was shocked that I'm no specialist like
an internist can make a radiology in
interpretation in the u.s. most
misdiagnosis happens it often leads to a
malpractice lawsuit in Japan the
stretching is different and it is far
from ideal
so I understand how this difference
drives you to make it more effective
what about geography because of the
geographical raise in Japan we also have
a very uneven distribution of doctors
most of them are concentrated in large
urban areas
this makes rural areas very stubbed for
specialist access my hometown is a
perfect example Hiroshima Prefecture is
surrounded by aliens
and mountainous areas with limited
access to specialists compare it to the
map of California and you can see how to
radiology
what telemedicine become very relevant I
see lots of islands difficult to access
all the experts are centralized
in big cities what about you mentioned
there is a third dimension so social
aspect what do you mean by that
yes in the Japanese society a female
radiologist often has to give up work to
support their yang family this
contributes even Wharton's caste of
radiologists for these three reasons I
believe to radiology is extremely
relevant in Japan I see so it makes
sense because I guess your platform
enables them to work part time tell us
how you approached teleradiology are you
a service company a product company what
exactly are you focusing on M&S provides
a response in two ways on the one hand
eminence is a product company our
product name is look like on the other
hand eminence is a service company these
two complement each other so what
exactly is the product our product
enables the radiologist to provide
reading services remotely to clinics
here's a movie of how we use look like
software to make diagnosis
we have some technical issues just a
second tell radiology platforms have
their limits okay
let me try to refresh this maybe
hmm okay we're gonna live without it so
basically there are two parts one apart
is the report reporting tool the other
part is the viewer tool so the
radiologists essentially inspects the
images in the viewer and simultaneously
creates the report you can also select
which slices you want to view and you
can manipulate the images in order to
make the correct diagnosis
so
okay so tell us a little bit about the
service component tamura-san M&R sim
provides two types of radiologists we
have eleven full-time radiologists
providing reading services using the
look great platform to our partner
clinics we also have part-time
radiologists to address changes in
demand we think of our platform as uber
for radiology to meet the dynamic market
demand so I hope you're not gonna start
hiring uber drivers for your
teleradiology but tell us about who pays
for the teleradiology service is that
the patient pays or is it an insurance
company how does that work in Japan
we have customers for both options all
Japanese people have government health
care plan which covers for some
radiology services some of our partners
for example Ginza clinic of our
direct-to-consumer amazing checkup which
includes a brain MRI plus interpretation
three experts radiologists cardiologists
and new radiologists for less than $200
so just - this was a shocking number for
me when I heard this so basically a
Japanese are known to be very interested
in health check-ups they're a private
companies direct-to-consumer that offer
a brain MRI scan for $200 completely
paid by the customer that offer a
check-up by a radiologist and
neuroradiologist and a cardiologist for
aneurysms so how does that make sense
because this number $200 is extremely
low compared to the US where a brain MRI
can cost north of $2000 that's a
complicated question let me offer two
data points
a typical salary for job Japanese
radiologists is around $120,000 do you
know what is a typical salary for us
radiologists
I think it's higher so just I want to
read the rate number
so I'm not a radiologist but the numbers
are like three or four times higher 120k
for a radiologist in Japan another data
point malpractice insurance in Japan
costs $600 a year in the u.s. my
understanding is that this number is
much higher does anyone actually know
how much a malpractice for radiologists
cost in a representative state fifty
thousand dollars and depends on state it
varies if you dependable you look
between 20 and 200k so I'm not sure
about that effect is but this different
rate contribute to the cost yes I
understand if you have your own
radiologist or if you don't have
radiologist but you have imaging
equipment you can benefit from Lu crack
how about clinics that don't even have
imaging devices a very good question for
this case we offer mobile cities service
mobile city is a dedicated truck loaded
with a CT scanner
it helps rural areas without a city
scanner we drive this mobile city to
where it's needed and get people scanned
we also use it for emporia screening
since Japanese law requires employers to
offer this service to their employees
once a year so this is was a very
interesting insight so my team had the
privilege of visiting MMS in Japan a
couple of months ago and we actually
visited this van we were inside his van
and the cameras on technician offered us
to run a presentation so none of us
wanted to volunteer for ionizing
radiation but we had the the little
anecdote I remember so we had the little
bento box lunch that the technician had
that day and he said that his wife made
it for him and he said I don't know
what's in it heavens I have not seen it
so he put it in the city and he scanned
it and we were able to figure out the
rice in the little tamagoyaki it was
like lots of interesting insights
so employers employers in Japan are
required by law to effor annual checkup
that includes a lung cancer screening
very interesting a difference that's
that's an interesting question
yeah I think there is a there is a there
is a different approach to risk
management in Japan it was insightful
for me as well I think that they also
try to striate patients so they
obviously you kind of have to hit the
right demographics and then it becomes
more relevant so stimulus and what is
your vision for for MS in the future so
far I have been talking about today
radio Dodgers model as it is now
but this is only our first step in the
future I envision three steps first
teleradiology second image based AI
algorithms that primarily look at the
images for prediction I third holistic
AI algorithms that look look at the
other data genomics demographics
nutrition for prediction I see so I
understand what image based the ISO you
primarily look at images can you tell us
like more specifics about how are you
using AI image diagnosis AIS algorithms
that use images as primary data source
we have started working with different
types of AI applications let me give you
a free example we are already using
today ai that can detect brain aneurysm
which is abnormal blood vessel breast
cancer is already used in daily clinical
practice City Lang nodule AI detector
for cancer diagnostics interesting to
note that the air models have different
quality for example ai for brain
aneurysm detection has 85 percent
sensitivity which makes it to useful
tool to double-check human radiology
let's play a movie to demonstrate how we
are using AI in Luke read product so
this was actually before we played the
movie I want to point out that this was
fascinating discovery because M Ness is
using AI algorithms already embedded in
their clinical workflow and these
algorithms are still in the process of
clinical validation but the specific
algorithm the brain under isn't cameras
unmentioned the brain the breast cancer
detection for MRI images and the CT lung
nodule detector it was very interesting
especially to see the feedback
collection piece which you will see in a
second I hope there is sound on this one
no sound
okay so I'm gonna make a voiceover for
this so essentially what you see here
the pictures are being sent to the cloud
the AI detects what is the right
algorithm in this case this is a brain
aneurysm and it detects that this is a
brain MRI so you have to apply them and
then the AI operates by detecting all
the places where it's expects and the
reason to appear all the results of the
eye are here on the right side and what
the screen allows the neurologist to do
is to provide feedback
so for example it marks as false
positive which means that the eye was
wrong
once the feedback has collected you can
press send feedback and it is being sent
to the developer of the algorithm
obviously sometimes the AI misses things
this is the false negatives so this is
an opportunity for the doctor to provide
two point-and-click where the AI missed
the diagnosis so this information is
being used by the application developer
in order to improve the algorithm
continuously
so this is how the user invokes the AI
and this is the the feedback screen
again
I use the Messiah system every day he
misdiagnosis with the AI would be the
standard in the near future but we
radiologists should not rely too much on
AI if you trust me I completely and
don't make diagnosis on your own your
diagnostic ability will decline in no
time present or take we should keep on
upward upgrading our ability and send
the diagnostic results to AI that would
improve a eyes accuracy therefore would
be benefit for patients so you know the
loaded question the elephant in the room
I don't know any radiologist in the room
okay maybe no elephant here but I can
tell you I can tell you when we give a
similar talk and an RSM a which is the
radiology Society in North America which
is 30,000 radiologists getting in the
middle of in the winter in Chicago the
question is like is so what's going on
here is AI going to replace radiologists
September Sam what is your take on this
this is indeed loaded question I know
that there is a healthy debate in my
professional radiology community here is
what I think will happen then your
future first we will see that over time
AI will keep bringing more and more
value as a decision support tool to help
human radiologists make more precise
decisions second we know that human
radiologists are valued for the
experience so we we will help human
radiologists focus on the truly
difficult cases
so one additional data point I'd like to
add is that the meme you hear in this
space is that AI is not going to replace
radiologists but radiologists that are
using a I will replace radiologists that
are not using AI because it's like
saying okay I'm not gonna use the
internet but if this is a tool that
allows you to be more productive and
the better care for your patients you
are not competitive if you're not gonna
use it right so another thing is to
think about AI in this context it's not
one black box that solves all the
problems of the world just like an auto
pilot in a plane is not one instrument
it is a collection if you ever looked
into a cockpit of a commercial airline
you know that it's a collection of
instruments each one is very dedicated
very focused and solves a very
particular problem now an autopilot is a
collection and they all work in tandem
with each other and they help the pilot
make better decisions the pilot this is
still the one who makes the final
decisions especially in the complicated
cases like taking off landing or during
turbulence so the same thing it is my
view that will happen in this space we
will see more and more tools like the
ones that cameras unmentioned developed
and being helpful to radiologists to
make them more productive so I also
think that there are a couple of
questions that the whole space is trying
to figure out specifically around
regulatory approval how do you think
about fda approval of AI model that by
definition is not fixed you know medical
device fixed you sign off the the sheets
you manufacture it and you're done if
you want to make a new device you need
to apply for regulatory approval again
AI by definition is something evolving
so fda right now is also evolving in how
it thinks about regulatory approval for
AI applications it also we actually work
with the fda closely in their program
where they try to adjust their approach
specifically until now the fda has been
focusing on providing regulatory
approval to products now they're more
experimenting with the idea that they
can provide regulatory approval to a
process so if you're compliant with a
process and they approve that process it
allows you to have more freedom to
operate an experiment very exciting
times so I'm gonna sum thank you this
were great examples I think and the
feedback collection piece I think is
very interesting
can you talk a little bit about holistic
AI and your
vision for that holistic AI means using
more than amazing data we want to help
patients collect different data types
medical record data genomics ad
nutrition data medication data exercise
that sleep data think of a look Reiki as
Google Drive for medical records once
this data is in the cloud
Emnes AI can analyze it and make useful
recommendations we have already studied
centralized management system including
medical interviews medical care and
pathological amazing in addition to
radiological amazing to integrate dog
data we use a Google account here in
this one some of you may have already
started working innovative na
applications we are very interested to
collaborate with partners to accelerate
our mission please come talk to us so
they were silent till now we've been
focusing on Japan is it are you only
working in Japan are you thinking of
going outside of the country Thank You
Ari
your question has good timing we are
very interested to go global let me give
an example
this man will launched a collaborative
project between Japan Mongolia to help
doctors in that country improved their
radiologic diagnostic quality the way it
works it through the network system of
eminence that connect to countries when
diagnostic radiologist or pathologist in
Mongolia face a difficult case they can
consult with experts based in Japan it's
similar to having senior doctors
advising junior doctors in a teaching
setting this helps patient and also
helps improve skills for Mongolian
doctors very interesting
so then once on you are now in cloud
next tell us a little bit your cloud
journey like how did you end up choosing
why Google many of our staff already use
Google services including gmail calendar
in Drive we wanted to build a
teleradiology as a service as simple as
logging into a gmail account
also Google Drive is a place where
people will store their line their files
we want to we want to build a place
where people can store their medical
images and data we also wanted a partner
of measurable sites that would enable us
to develop
telemedicine services that would be
reliable and scalable we also have
global goals and we wanted a global
partner most importantly we saw Google
as a partner with a vision that is allow
aligned to ours democratize access to a
high-quality care universally we'll see
our goal achieved through telemedicine
so it sounds like you had quite a
checklist for your requirements I'm
happy that we were able to meet your
expectations Emerson thank you yeah I
wanted to ask you about some of the
challenges around cloud so in the u.s.
we're learning that healthcare space
financial space and other regulated
industries like government they're
slowly warming up to the idea of using
cloud for their data storage and
processing how is this happening in
Japan what kind of challenges were you
facing when you were approaching
healthcare providers we have indeed
observed a gradually increasing will
willingness to use cloud solutions in
the healthcare space and we think it's
very exciting we think it has to do with
two reasons first most financial
institutions in Japan are moving to the
cloud and that sends a strong signal to
other industry
is like health care second because japan
produces so much amazing data the cost
efficiency of storing the data on
premise becomes the less and less
economical for hospitals they are
looking for effective solutions and here
cloud can provide we are very
interesting so when you're deploying
lucre is it like a pure cloud or a
hybrid approach how does that work in
the present because many of our
customers are asking for additional
backup storage we offer hybrid solution
which keeps most of the data in the data
center in Tokyo and some of the data on
premise in the hospital we also know
that Google is planning to open another
data center in Osaka this will enable us
to move to a pure cloud solution which
will make our IT management easier makes
sense so as we are about to wrap up like
what are you most excited about the
future tomorrow what do you see the most
opportunity here I am excited about
three things first I want to see M&S
become a truly global initiative bring
spit eristic sput is where it's needed
the most second we want to advance the
role of AI in terror radiology we want
to integrate more AI algorithms into our
clinical work third we want to find
partners that can use a platform to
solve problems like rare diseases if any
of these resonate with you please come
talk to us
we are welcoming potential collaboration
we would like to make our look like a
tool that can improve patient lives this
is our mission and nothing would make me
happier than that
take your time we're something I think
this is gonna to wrap up one of the
examples of very fruitful partnership
because Luke rec brings a lot of the
products go Google is building
showcasing what what is possible to do
with them and it also enables other
partners the ones that develop the AI
applications to be tested accelerated
and developed further so this is an
example of how Google cloud is
approaching the partner first ecosystem
in order to solve very specific
challenges in the healthcare space
[Music]